comunque tanti ragazzi su e chissà che
questa domenica mi sto mettendo in modo
tale da fare un episodio non alla
settimana come una volta però ogni tanto
rifaccia il mi riporta indietro anche
questo periodo è quello di rievocare
vecchi ricordi quindi anche se l'ho già
fatto questa domenica perché dire no
tout move new haven non mi sono mai
piaciuti i don't move perché io ti
mollano gioco web di video e lo iodio
gioco degli one dati video che io cristo
ora vi ricordate no io devo cristo nare
su un livello dove poi cristo nate su di
me che io cristiano solo diventano un
guardo c'è shaun capito chi your bones
fix
ancora ma torna sto livello ci aveva 86
anni ko mica l'ho lanciato come piazza
fatta la giapponese come come ho fatto a
lanciarlo ho fatto 9 pato non sono mai
riuscito a fare prima bisogna lanciare
una persona non lancia come ho fatto non
lo so ma lo ha lanciato da poi a di
propulsione su una tizia cia grado
va bene primo livello già lo si è capito
un cacchio però va bene così ragazzi
molto altro forse più giuseppina in
realtà è una bottiglia due botti una
loggia rotta sipro ragazzi prova che mi
stanno dando del nobel non ho fatto
ancora niente
vorrei capirlo ci sono solo due
piattaforme un po una merda come bottle
devo perché quella al latte impossibile
proprio nulla beh basta casa sì perché
se cosa 26 anni ragazzi de l'alchimista
bentornate non l'ho mai cup quello con
l'elicottero che
non è al traguardo che lo stava puntando
tantissimo perché avevo visto subito dal
traguardo sarà davvero sarà molto più
avanti propri fa ridere che non che il
livello trova non si capisce niente va
bene e non ho idea di dove possa essere
traguardo scusa hanno toccato vinto è
stato facile quale era l'altro lancia
spiega vi facciamo gol pongo qual è la
trovata cli chi è
ok è un livello di merda ragazzi è
importante averlo vinto con l'elicottero
però gay straight stop al 3 giu stop e
quando di quando ti fai i massaggi alla
schiena ma ti spingono troppo e ti spari
questo è quello che mi succeda orti qua
ti devi fermare teoricamente c'è tutti
gli spari alla velocità pazzesca e
l'obiettivo è fermarti prima che il
personaggio arrivi alla fine
semplicemente questo discorso solo che
non ho idea di come per amico luogo
forse ce l'ho fatta
non lo so sì ce l'ho fatta sono fattori
soffermato molto prima molto prima di
arrivare alla fine tatami sono voci
entrare per un traguardo il che è molto
biffi si vabbè ma di un attimo
oddio mi sono trasformato e stato
bellissimo
proprio lui certo la cosa diventato
optimus prime prova niente normal sword
prove da un botto che non faccio un
altro normale non mi sembra normale se
gli occhi c'è una bottiglia prova prende
la sola bottiglia
porca vacca stavo dicendo a fare il
botto il flip vabbé peccato no no
grazie a posto farei uk not work tre
possibili che è successo ma anche fuori
se fai fuori il padre di luca per questa
cosa non la potevo sapere rifacciamo
senza colpire lui ma
io l'ho preso a posto
o poche spade però quello il problema
quindi con uno ha dovuto farne due
quindi sono riuscito benissimo morse
works for you
avrai beve
no chao rock swing nascosto sti stronzi
nuovo visto ok
e aveva quarto lungo suo livello arai
bra e
35 quasi non è normale next one abbiamo
ragazzi sul 99 per cento impossible che
mi sembra abbas
ok aspetta se io arrivo di testa va dall
no
gioco forza se non mi beccavo quando
allora devo riuscire a non farmi al
pianale in alto
ci credo lavoro schivati tutti porco le
ma ora vorrei provarci se non è qualcosa
riesco a fare però non so in che modo
forse devo saltare più avanti non lo so
se noemi devono spingere sul traguardo
ma non so bene in che modo ho dato una
testata tutto ok veramente lì forse il
più difficile degli ultimi tempi ma come
capri o sono anche abbastanza censurato
proprio lui due ore ci ho messo va beh
non sfruttato sto compiuta da 20 mila
euro solo per fare questo impostino
cento per cento impossible speak sarebbe
spike però fa niente facciamo un fispic
nel senso che è un livello proprio di
speak che risalta rispetto agli altri la
buy let's go
in realtà mi sentivo la vittoria però
riproviamoci ragazzi devo andare un po
più lento ok questa buonissima questa
posizione
cinque secondi precisi pazzesco the
random cool guy thank you so much
ragazzo però il fatto suo livello let's
go out the next chop chop band scusa
sarebbe ciò per ciò che tutti
[Musica]
ma che è una sorta di impossible dovevo
passare attraverso delle maniglie prete
impossibile provare a volare
ma se longo lo annuncia farò mai come
farà ci aspettavamo e fa volare
aurea my brother prendere se si può
anche finire in modo l'egida anche se
effettivamente con le ladies perché
nessuno ha detto che non si lodava sta
roba quindi la madonna è veramente un
casino
passando in mezzo non lo puoi finire
passando in mezzo ai imponibile
vabbè allora forse composto la prima
fatica miei personaggi vabbè ma ditelo
che ne sono ma noi l'idea vedrai teheran
alla corsa sulle scale va bene
è un massaggio luke erano massaggi shops
mi faccio col cazzo età
ok
minchia che atterraggio per no vabbè ma
ragazzi perfetto ma la c che cosa ciò
oggi ne ho fatti tantissimi livelli sono
stato bravissimo però a fare un paio di
livelli va il mio nome con i vecchi
tempi non c'è ancora qualcuno che
cercano un miliardo papi gay e il pene
che vola il bene che voglio
grazie signor antonio 8 grazie mille
caro non solo ringraziato questo livello
anche questa ha mosso qualcosa dentro di
me fa vicino al 90 per cento test
iniziative facile fare se fai questo
test e sono sempre lei sarai un pro
player va bene così lo devo fare zio
specie impulsivi impossibile da 3 per
cento dicitura questa però sai un pro
player
sì ma la domanda è con cosa lo faccio
con
non ci
sono caduto l'accaduto e sono molto alte
come traguardo e dietro ragazzi perché
mi sa che l'ho visto per sbaglio tutto a
proposito probabile celebre casa anche
in avanti non solo sapremo mai ma adesso
sto sbagliato andare con il padre di
duke
sbagliarli tutti e gioca questo gioco da
una vita ok
va bene allora dello stivale primo
arpione fin qua ok poi è la prima è una
cagata l'abbiamo capito però è la
seconda che mi crea problemi perché la
seconda di spara subito
ok ok
mamma mia
sono dieci anni che gioca sta roba
ragazzi e già fa ridere così è comunque
ragazzi siamo anche oggi giunti alla
fine l'episodio 210 e b6 e per il
pazzesco ragazzi ci pensate si chiede
anche ai ragazzi lasciato un bel mi
piace un commento qua sotto e noi come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
bella ragazzi
[Musica]